-Welcome, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And happy Halloween, everybody!
You can tell I'm in
the Halloween spirit.
I've been wearing my
Jimmy Kimmel costume
for almost two months now.
Well, this is fun.
Earlier tonight, President Biden
and the First Lady
welcomed trick-or-treaters
to The White House
for the first fully in-person
Halloween celebration
since the pandemic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Yep, Halloween was back at
The White House,
and it was
a nice chance to reuse
Melania's Christmas decorations.
[ Laughter ]
Trick-or-treaters were psyched.
Every kid went home with
a bag of candy.
It was different than
the last administration,
when every kid went home with a
bag of classified documents.
[ As Trump ] Only take one.
Only take one
classified document.
Meet you at Mar-a-Lago."
[ Normal voice ]
I read that some of the
most popular Halloween candies
this year are
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups,
KitKats, and Snickers.
But there are
some candies out there
that people don't like as much.
Tariq, do you think
you can give us
some tips on
which candies to avoid?
-Do I? Hit it.
♪♪
♪ Candy corn,
you can take a back seat ♪
♪ You're tacky, waxy,
bad as rancid crab meat ♪
♪ Necco Wafer,
you're inedible rock ♪
♪ Just a swole-ass Smartie
that takes like chalk ♪
♪ Don't even get me started on
Good & Plentys ♪
♪ You taste like pennies,
more like Bad & Too Manys ♪
♪ And Milk Duds? ♪
♪ Get away from me ♪
♪ Won't get you out of my teeth
until Christmas Eve ♪
♪ And Jujubes,
you get an ew from me ♪
♪ I'd rather chew blue cheese
mixed with prune juice, please ♪
♪ And, Dots, how 'bout not? ♪
♪ You can rot in the box ♪
♪ Gimme Twix, Junior Mints,
anything but a dot ♪
♪ Gimme Reese's, Snickers,
Crunch, or Runts ♪
♪ But gimme Laffy Taffy,
and I'll punch your guts ♪
♪ I'll take anything
out of desperation ♪
♪ If the only other option
is a box of raisins ♪
-Oh, come on, now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on. Come on, now.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Oh, my!
-That's amazing.
The greatest!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Tariq Trotter! Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey, guys, I saw that,
this weekend,
former president Obama
was campaigning in Michigan.
And when he started talking
about getting older,
some women in the crowd
chimed in.
Take a look at this.
-I have to admit that sometimes
going out on the campaign trail
feels a little harder
than it used to.
Not just because
I'm older and grayer.
-Fine little...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-I don't know
if y'all heard that.
Said I was still fine.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fine?
Then Michelle was like,
"Yeah, I think we're done with
the campaign speeches, alright?"
He's like, "I'm Barack Obama.
I approved this message."
That's the one difference
between Obama and Biden.
When Obama is onstage,
people are like, "He is fine."
And when Biden is onstage,
people are like, "He's fine."
"He's fine."
That's right -- the Democrats
have deployed Obama
on the campaign trail.
Tell me you're nervous
about the midterms
without telling me you're
nervous about the midterms.
Some business news.
In Elon Musk's first round of
layoffs at Twitter,
he reportedly plans to fire
25% of the company's workforce.
Meanwhile, Facebook said,
"We're hiring."
Everyone was like, "No, thanks."
But Twitter is actually
trying to hire replacements,
and we found some questions
on the application
that Elon Musk is sending out.
And here are
some of the questions.
They're very interesting here.
Let's check some of these out.
First one says...
-Wow!
-Next up, there's...
After that, it asked...
"V-Bucks, please." Yep.
Then it says...
These are odd questions.
-Yeah.
-And, finally, it asks...
-Wow!
-I don't know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good luck.
But did you see this, though?
Elon Musk tweeted something that
was considered misinformation
and then deleted it later
because it was
a false conspiracy theory.
Which is awkward when
you're the owner of Twitter.
Here was the e-mail
that Musk received. It said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a lot to figure...
Meanwhile, I saw that to reduce
the amount of misinformation
on their platform,
YouTube will now let
doctors and nurses
apply for their videos
to be marked as reliable.
-Ooh!
-Yeah.
YouTube finally looked at
all their misinformation
on their site and said...
-Ain't nobody got time for that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So now people who
post fake information online
are freaking out, like...
-[ Bleating loudly ]
-Because if they keep
spreading lies,
YouTube might step in
and stop them, kind of like...
-The question is, how do
democracies respond to...
-And what will it mean for...
-But people need to know which
sources to trust
or they could fall
for anything, like...
-Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
-Or they might jump to wrong
conclusions, kind of like...
♪♪
-♪ Sail ♪
-So if you're spreading
misinformation,
it's got to come down,
kind of like...
And, please, always make sure
your sources are reliable
or nothing you say
will make sense, kind of like...
-What do you think?
-I like turtles.
-Yeah, there you go.
I hope that helped.
I hope that helped everybody.
"Hi, Billy."
-"Hey, Ron."
[ Both laugh ]
[ Imitates crashing ]
"Hey, Ron."
-"Hey, Billy."
Some more business news.
Spirit Airlines just revealed
upgraded, larger seats
that they're adding to
their new planes.
-Ooh!
-They're all on the wing,
but, still, it's something.
That's right -- larger seats.
But to maximize profits,
they'll make you
spoon with another passenger.
Well, get this.
I heard that nearly 150,000
pounds of chicken patties
sold at Costco
have been recalled
'cause there might be
plastic in it.
150,000 pounds of chicken.
Thankfully, at Costco,
that's just one package.
Finally, some thieves
in Georgia were arrested
after police found them
by following
a trail of candy wrappers
in the woods.
The judge must have had fun
with the story
because their bail was
100 grand.
We have a great show.